lockdown measures are strictly enforced
all the places that are empty now arenas
schools public places streets police
were called after some customers started
fighting over toilet paper in water with
Slash red tape to develop vaccines and
therapies as fast as it can possibly be
done drugs that were developed
originally for HIV and for the flu and
their anecdotes of them being used in
people getting better in the virus is
clearing very quickly we must look out
for each other
we must toll each other through this
because if there's one thing that is
more contagious than this virus it is
love and compassion
I don't have to say anything we all know
these are unprecedented times since the
first report of covert 19 and Wuhan
China it has spread all over the globe
as China grappled with the crisis the
world watched it seemed distant to most
but then slowly and surely a wave of
infections began to appear in your city
governments health officials and the
public scrambled to make sense of the
situation and drastic changes were made
for many the ceasing of everyday life
has become a surreal shock not
experienced since the Second World War
it's a difficult time for most as
confusion and uncertainty prevail there
certainly been chaos but also hope in
this episode we'll be covering some of
the tools that have been used to battle
the disease scientists and doctors
around the world are using the internet
to publish information faster than ever
before
this has yielded some potential
solutions while we wait for a vaccine
that could be over a year away
treatments with existing drugs have
shown to be working in very early trials
this special episode will include a chat
I had with dr. Gerald Evans an
infectious disease specialist from
Canada we'll get to the solutions a bit
later but first we must understand the
enemy
[Music]
kovat 19 otherwise known as the corona
virus is an infectious disease caused by
the size cough - virus it's around 10 to
34 times more fatal than the flu though
it's hard to know exactly how many
people have milder cases so the true
fatality rate may be lower the
incubation period of the virus has been
reported to be around 2 to 14 days with
a median of 5 to 6 days one case studies
suggest that the incubation period could
extend out to 24 days although this
hasn't been verified widely but this
long incubation period is what makes
this disease dangerous you can be
infected for quite a while and not feel
sick while unknowingly passing it to
others this phenomena is known as
asymptomatic transmission a joint study
by 7 researchers found that over 80% of
the people in blue hair weren't recorded
and most of them weren't showing severe
symptoms speaking of which what are the
symptoms of this illness
well according to one study the most
common symptom is a fever at 87% of
people experiencing that and then a dry
cough at 67% and next fatigue at 38% but
interestingly there's some new data
suggesting that a loss of smell may be
an early indicator studies have shown
that the virus can live on surfaces
anywhere from a few hours to a couple of
days depending on the surface material
as you've all heard this is why you
should practice frequent and thorough
hand washing and also avoid touching
your mouth nose and eyes where the virus
can enter so why does washing your hands
work well the virus has a fatty layer on
its outside which breaks down with soap
destroying its effectiveness so
something that's not really talked about
is how exactly this virus kills people
it's a bit grim but it's important
information
although Kovan 19 can damage the kidneys
heart and male reproductive organs kovat
19 kills by the development of acute
respiratory distress syndrome or a RDS
for short it all starts with our lungs
think of it like this if the main part
of our lungs are a tree trunk and
branches our alveoli are the leaves
there's a little tiny sacs on the end of
our lungs
that extract oxygen from our blood human
lungs have about 600 million alveoli a
RDS is worse than pneumonia because with
pneumonia it's only a local inflammation
whereas a RDS in flames all of the
alveoli across the entire lung the
inflammation of the alveoli stops oxygen
from getting into them and to make
things worse they fill up with liquid
the consequence is that you can't
breathe and without intervention you
could suffocate to stop this a patient
with a RDS will need ventilation until
the swelling goes down in some cases
this can take upwards of two weeks
remember this detail this is why
hospitals are quickly running out of
space it's because people that need
intensive care and need assistance
breathing can stay in there for a long
time and this is why it's so important
to stop the spread of this disease let's
talk about that
[Music]
the point is slowly getting across now
but until recently many people were
still dismissive about this to them this
was just the flu and a big fuss over
nothing but they didn't understand the
problem the first part of the problem
lies in mathematics it seems that people
don't understand Exponential's
admittedly
they're unintuitive to us humans a good
example popularized by Chris Martenson
is as follows imagine a baseball stadium
if he started with a drop of water that
doubles every two seconds guess how long
it would take to fill up a few days a
couple of weeks a year not even close
who would take 50 minutes to fill up
even more and intuitively at 45 minutes
the stadium would be 93% empty
in other words 93% of the stadium is
filled up in the last five minutes
this is essentially the same law that
the virus follows it's essentially an
exponential growth pattern for example
one person infects two and two people in
fact four and four people in fact eight
etc and by the time you know it the
numbers have exploded to put that into
perspective to what's happening now the
first 100,000 cases took 90 days the
second hundred thousand cases took 12
days and the third hundred thousand
cases took four days so to explain why
this is happening we need to discuss
something called an R naught factor this
represents on average how many people a
single person can infect a value above 1
means the virus will spread and below 1
means the virus will die out but the
thing is the R naught value is not
intrinsic to the virus it depends on
environmental conditions and the
behavior of a culture or society
according to multiple epidemiology teams
this novel coronavirus
is said to have an R naught between one
point four and five point five so one
person could spread it to more than five
people but we have the power to change
this value for example in South Korea
extreme amounts of testing allowed for
the locations of the virus
so people and their contacts could be
isolated this greatly reduced the spread
of the disease and so far they've got it
under control
flattening the curve
it was first trending on Twitter a few
weeks ago and then soon every government
official was saying it and now I'm sure
we've all heard of it it's the practice
of social distancing otherwise known as
the physical distancing to slow the rate
of spread so that hospital systems don't
become overwhelmed with those who are
most at risk at first most people
thought it was the elderly and those
would underlying health conditions but
later data is starting to show that
younger people are starting to end up in
trouble and nobody seems to know exactly
why just yet for some practical examples
he is the difference between two cities
in Italy Bergamo and Lodi Lodi had the
first case of covert 19 in all of Italy
and implemented a shutdown on February
3rd while Bergamo waited until March 8th
we also have some hard data from the
Spanish flu of 1918 he is the difference
between mitigation and no mitigation in
two different cities Philadelphia and
st. Louis so most countries were too
late to implement South Korea's policy
but flattening the curve does work but
there is one major problem with it it
intrinsically kills economies and this
is why a lot of governments were very
slow to adopt the measure some of you
may have heard of this but it's a pretty
interesting anecdote one lady he became
known as patient 31 defied calls to get
tested and instead went to a buffet and
two packed church services where she
ended up infecting over a thousand
people according to the Korea Center for
disease and control prevention
she may see well handedly have caused
80% of the virus cases in South Korea so
that's an example of what not to do and
why it's important to keep social
interactions to a minimum okay so now
that we're familiar with the virus let's
move on to some good news let's discuss
some of the emerging treatments that are
coming out now
so for right now a vaccine is out of the
question most experts think that's at
least a year away so why is so slow well
vaccines have to go through many stages
before they're deemed safe I'll give you
one example to highlight why this takes
time back in the 2000s scientists were
trying to make a sized vaccine in
animals the vaccine elicited an immune
response and produced antibodies like it
was supposed to so that seemed good but
upon reinfection the immune system of
the subject animals went into overdrive
and killed the animal so we really don't
want to rush something out like that to
the entire human population that being
said phase one trials have started in
Seattle and are set to start in other
places around the world because of these
desperate warlike conditions scientists
are skipping past the animal trials and
going straight to human subjects this is
very risky but the scientists conclude
that it's necessary while we wait for a
vaccine a treatment is needed for
infected patients or even as a
preventative measure to stop people from
getting ill in the first place I'm not
going to go through all of them here but
just for your information there's at
least 35 possible treatments that are
showing promise if you're interested in
reading more about them I'll leave a
link below however out of all of these
there's one that's standing above the
rest hydroxychloroquine it comes in
another form called chloroquine and
we'll be talking about both here these
drugs are interesting not just because
of their potential but also because of
the controversy surrounding them from
being hailed as a cure for the corona
virus to being blamed for the death of a
60 year old man who took covert 19
treatment into his own hands it's a
bizarre story but let's try and cut
through the noise and figure out what's
going on here
chloroquine has a long history during
the 1600s in Peru the indigenous people
extracted the bark from the cinchona
plant
they used this bark to fight chills and
fever in 1934 chloroquine was first
identified in Western science and used
for malaria since then it's had a wide
range of uses anything from HIV
treatment to autoimmune diseases
according to Lancet Infectious Diseases
there aren't any significant detrimental
side effects but recently this has come
under debate and we'll talk about this
later so how does it work the following
information is from dr. C healed of med
cram so here's a cell in your body and
this is a virus inside of it is some RNA
replication instructions drawn in green
the viruses like to attach to something
called an ace 2 receptor which is found
in large amounts inside of our lungs
once the virus attaches itself it
releases its RNA into ourselves sadly
our cells internal machinery read the
RNA which gives it instructions to
produce more of the virus RNA the corona
virus has basically hijacked ourselves
to make more of itself once the
replication is complete the new viruses
detach themselves and go off to infect
more cells repeating the process so what
can be done well it turns out that
thinking iron form disrupts this
replication process so if everyone just
takes ink tablets we'll be fine right
well wrong zinc basically has zero
intracellular penetration when consumed
in other words zinc ions can't get into
a cell by themselves in order to do that
they need something called an ion is for
essentially an i honest form is a key
that unlocks the door for zinc to get
through into the cell in addition to
changing the pH levels in such a way
that stops the virus and bonding
chloroquine is an ion is for and this is
where things get interesting
[Music]
early studies fork over 19 treatment are
showing promising science a French study
conducted tests on 36 patients 20 were
treated with the drug and 16 were a
control group after six days a hundred
percent of the 20 patients tested
negative this number was less than 20%
for the control group
although encouraging this study has been
criticized for its design and dr. Evans
also says not so fast the the issue with
other things like hydroxychloroquine the
use of an HIV drug called Cottrell pinna
vir ritonavir it's a mixture and even
the use of an antibiotic called
azithromycin that's a little bit more
tough to decide whether or not we're
actually seeing a good signal of
effectiveness and the reason for that is
that most of those have been in open
label use in other words a physician's
just decided I got nothing to lose here
I'm just going to give it to the patient
and maybe that patient would have
improved anyways so we really need
trials that look at comparators of
similar patients who did get it and
didn't get it and I guess I am
optimistically hopeful that
hydroxychloroquine or chloroquine which
is a relatively cheap generic drug that
at least you know if we can gather
enough data they may work and who's the
right person to use it in and when
should we use it and those are big
unanswered questions that we may not
really have the answers to until this
has really gone into its later phase but
I'm cautiously optimistic how's that I
probably should have started negative
prevented me all these other words from
fire despite this everyone from China to
Norway Australia France and the United
States and many other countries are
employing chloroquine or it's safer
cousin hydroxychloroquine
hydroxychloroquine has been shown to be
40 percent less toxic in animal studies
in late march the indian national task
force instructed doctors to take
hydroxychloroquine as a preventative
measure against cope at 19
so how did we get here how did
scientists pick chloroquine a
decades-old drug as a candidate to
battle covet 19 as far back as 2005
experiments on cells showed a 90%
reduction in the SARS coronavirus when
treated with chloroquine though this
study was limited as the drug was only
added five hours after infection though
the interesting part was that
chloroquine showed a hundred percent
prevention of the SARS virus with just
10 micrograms meaning that it may even
prevent the SARS coronavirus in the
first place the conclusion of this study
basically was this is extremely
effective but we need more studies in
animals reason being the results of
experiments in cells may not translate
100% in living flesh fast forward 15
years and a Chinese study in the 4th of
February twenty twenty pound and a
hundred percent destruction of kovat 19
with just 10 micrograms again this was
done in cell culture and not in humans
nevertheless the study concluded quote
chloroquine is a cheap and safe drug
that has been used for more than 17
years
therefore it is potentially clinically
applicable against the 2019 end cough
around the same time in early february
chloroquine phosphate was selected from
tens of thousands of existing drugs to
fight covert 19 by chinese scientists a
press conference was held to announce
this On February 17th Chinese scientists
ran a trial of a hundred patients in ten
hospitals they concluded that the drug
should be included in the official
guidelines of Kovan 19 at this time
while the world was battling the crisis
word of the Chinese studies started
reverberating around the world soon
South Korea would also issue guidelines
including chloroquine as an effective
treatment
on March 10th 2020 Raymond James and
Associates wrote a piece titled if a
covert 19 therapy doesn't benefit a
stock doesn't even exist
and in the piece you can hear the
frustration of medical researchers quote
you may not have read much about
chloroquine yet since it doesn't benefit
any stocks if we had to pick a treatment
at this point that actually seems most
likely to have the biggest impact on
trading covert 19 in the coming years
and months it would be chloroquine they
go on chloroquine shouldn't be left out
of the discussion of covert 19 therapies
and may actually be leading the pack
interestingly the pattern for
chloroquine expired long ago so now it's
a generic drug meaning that there's no
money to be made on March 17th a trial
of the medication began in fifty
hospitals in Queensland Australia as of
March 23rd over 20 more hospitals across
Australia have asked to use
hydroxychloroquine in studies with over
2,400 patients what we're doing is we're
going to look at 2,400 Australians and
rigorously study these drugs and see
what happens
but you suspect it's the magic of the
combination do you that's what we
suspect how confident are you that these
drugs will work you know my guess is
that this is probably going to be about
80% there 80% chance of success on 18th
of March the news outlet Axios
reported that the drug company Bayer
will supply chloroquine to the US
government for potential use if approved
so all of this was looking bright for
the drug until March the 20th
on the 20th of March in a press
conference Donald Trump had announced
that the FDA had approved chloroquine
for the fight against Coppa 19 it is
known as a malaria drug and it's been
around for a long time and it's very
powerful the drug chloroquine has been
used to treat malaria since 1944 early
testing in the u.s. show it's effective
at preventing and treating severe acute
respiratory syndrome or SARS a close
cousin to covert 19 just minutes later
the FDA came out and said that this
wasn't the case
however the drug would be fast-tracked
and looked at harder for a potential
treatment a lot of red tape would be cut
after this something strange happened
though after the announcement people
rushed out and bought and at the
medication presumably to use it to
protect themselves against covert 19
this took the drug away from those who
actually needed it for their health
hoarding the medication is truly unfair
to those who need it
it's the selfish action that could leave
honorable people stranded and seriously
at risk news outlets like Bloomberg in
The New York Times ran reports saying
that Trump mentioning the drug as a
possible game changer was irresponsible
people came out of the woodwork saying
that the drugs were dangerous and could
cause a mass number of deaths this was
all happening while I was researching it
was bizarre to see the script flip so
quickly in real time a French professor
who ran a clinical trial using the drug
against covert 19
expressed his shock at how these
commonly used drugs were suddenly being
labeled as poison at just the precise
point where the world needs them he said
yeah my fans a little medical you don't
see called kinky boys keep Tom Tom Tom
Tom Chris he does it stem plays also so
there's I'm not like all the illusions
brizl see absolutely lose ourselves with
Carol the main reason for the negative
sentiment is that people going to take
ID Roxy chloroquine without professional
medical guidance and this is indeed
dangerous on March 23rd a 60 year old
man consumed fish tank cleaner with
chloroquine as an active ingredient the
formula was different to the medical
verse
of the drug and the man ended up dying
not only this but if you have a heart
condition chloroquine can actually be
fatal as it causes heart irregularities
to add to this blindness is a rare but a
known side effect of long-term use there
are also negative interactions with
existing medications which have to be
looked at the studies mentioned earlier
screened for these risks and excluded
candidates that would have a bad
reaction of the anecdotes I've read most
mentioned no side-effects but some do
complain of nausea and even peeling of
the skin looking at the official common
side effects most of them seem to be
pretty mild but it's the rare reactions
that are concerning and it shouldn't
have to be said but in no way should you
take a drug like this without medical
guidance despite these extraordinary
events some doctors are already
prescribing hydroxychloroquine to
infected patients after assessing the
risks and it is just tentatively showing
to be effective now joining us via zoom
is dr. Jeff Collier he's the former
governor of Kansas and a practicing
physician who wrote an eye-opening op-ed
in the Wall Street Journal advocating
the use of hydroxychloroquine in two
ways to treat patients and as a
prophylaxis to protect health care
workers from infection we looked at the
data we looked at hearing what was going
on around the world and after the test
tube confirmation we found there's a
crunch study and then also a Chinese
study and several anecdotal reports that
this is an effective drug and frankly
it's our only option
what we want to do is we are treating
those patients who have tested positive
we are also treating their immediate
family members that they are quarantined
in with as well the second group that
we're looking at is for providers who
have a serious exposure the EMT who
intubated somebody in the field making
sure that they get a course of this
medication also though people seem to
have a better outcome when given early
to them and that is the bottom line here
there is some hope anecdotally it
tentatively seems to be working but we
should still be cautious in our optimism
well he he was basically on death's door
for the first couple days in the ICU
they gave him a very low survival a
chance and about two days into his stay
in the ICU they put him on the medicine
and he's taken a significant turn for
the better and looks like he's gonna
mind it oh thank goodness
there's a direct correlation of me
taking it and me feeling better ten
hours later fifty two-year-old Rio
Jardin airy says the reason he's still
alive is because hydroxychloroquine an
old anti malaria medicine it started out
with it with the fever and the headache
and then progressed a heavy sweating and
then I got developed a very bad pain and
like doctors put him on oxygen in the
ICU but he says he was still unable to
breathe after more than a week in
isolation with it getting harder to
breathe
he said his goodbyes to his wife and
three children certain people in the
world you can't shut out of the Bell
saying goodbye to you and no matter who
you are no matter what scenario and
you're never prepared then a friend sent
him a recent article about
hydroxychloroquine it has already proven
successful to treat coronavirus patients
overseas though it hasn't been approved
by health officials after some
back-and-forth with an infectious
disease doctor he was authorized to take
the drug basically welcome baby exactly
4:45 in the morning with no symptoms it
was pretty crazy I looked around woke up
looked directly at the clock and it
dawned on me wait a minute I can breathe
my wife says what's wrong with you I
thought he introduced you sound normal
that was a sure sign I had somebody gone
right he sense had no fever or pain
feels fine and he's able to breathe
again
yeah I'm 100% convinced this is what
saved my life although it's not
completely settled and there is some
controversy over it many researchers do
you think that it could turn the tide in
the battle against the virus but
fundamentally we'll just have to wait
for the results of these studies to make
sure like dr. Gerald Evans said maybe
these people might have gotten better
anyway it could be possible that the
chloric ones are just a big red herring
but I really hope that's not the case
I'm going to be so interested in seeing
the results of further studies
he is former FDA Commissioner dr. Scott
Gottlieb on the issue the
hydroxychloroquine the president keeps
saying there's a good chance that it
could have a great impact can you
separate fact from fiction well look it
is being used that this drug was being
used off-label by doctors around the
country prior to it sort of becoming the
subject of a lot of discussion at it at
a national level the data there's is
both in vitro data meaning and test
tubes as well as clinical data coming
out of China and also a study out of
France
it's very preliminary and it's a very
small number of patients I'm certainly
something that we should follow up on
and they're going to be proper clinical
trials underway it must also be noted
that this kind of treatment can't be
used on patients who are too far
advanced in their illness this is
because by the time they're in serious
trouble the virus has pretty much left
the system at this point leaving the
body to fight it off and at this point
antivirals aren't going to work hot on
the heels of the chloric winds is
another drug showing promise
it's a Japanese flu drug called for VP
review it works through the same
ionosphere mechanisms as chloroquine a
Chinese clinical study of 340 patients
showed 91% improved versus 62% of the
control group the head of China's
science and technology ministry stated
quote it has a high degree of safety and
is clearly effective in treatment in
quote a Chinese study in late March
showed the possibility of using the
blood of the recovered to treat the sick
in the study five critically ill
patients were given antivirals and we're
in ICU the doctors gave them blood
plasma that contained antibodies of
covert 19 survivors the results AR D s
resolved in 12 days and three patients
were released from hospital while the
other two are stable so that doctors
don't have to go around finding
survivors and taking their blood is
proposed that the cells that actually
make the antibodies can be cloned and
then be used to produce a mass treatment
again this is hopeful but these are
early days and we have to wait for more
studies
along with the over 30 other treatments
that are being looked at there's a good
chance that we could have some options
to fight covert 19 in the coming months
so there is a reason to have some
tentative hope
although this is a hard time it's
important to note that progress is being
made some of the smartest minds are
pulling together all say in this whole
situation there's been a remarkable side
effect that have seen a shared sense of
adversity has done something interesting
it's brought people together community
is starting to come back after its
erosion in the past thirty years I've
seen strangers on Facebook offering to
help the elderly get their groceries
I've seen groups come together to help
nurses and check on their mental health
yes some people were panic buying and
fighting in stores but these other
groups of people are showing that we can
rise above this tough time could make us
realize what's important in life loving
each other family and helping each other
and that's encouraging to see so that's
about it but I have to give a very
important shout-out to the nurses and
the doctors who were working hard on the
frontlines and all of this would very
little direction from their respective
governments you guys are the literal
heroes the soldiers on the frontlines
thank you for the amazing work that you
are doing and lastly to everyone out
there we're going to get through this
scientists and researchers across the
globe are fighting this it's a
collaborative effort not seen since the
Second World War and the best news of
all have seen vlogs from people living
in China and they're starting to emerge
from this disaster it's early proof that
this eventually will end in the meantime
please stay safe in good humor I'll
leave you with a few gems from Italy's
quarantine we all got a laugh right
[Music]
if you brought at home and just want to
see some more core stuff I have hundreds
of videos on my channel that you can
binge in the next episode we'll see how
technology is helping in the covert 19
battle food drones delivering medicine
to robots autonomously disinfecting
hospitals with UV light artificial
intelligence is getting involved in lung
CT scans to take the load of doctors and
also to analyze your cough to diagnose
you instantly all of this and more in
the next episode of cold fusion thanks
for watching my name is Tiger go
you'll be watching cold fusion and I'll
see you again soon for the next episode
cheers guys stay safe
[Music]
any thinking
you